this is bear son it was the home of your
grandparents and their grandparents
before then but out there beyond the age
of the water-wise the whole of the
Dragons
and I believe that your destiny to one
day find this hidden world
you do know my leg isn't a chew toy
don't you is this what you want yeah
okay
how am I supposed to get down hey buddy
wait up he's not the only one
[Music]
another Night Fury is more like a right
I like hearing yeah yours is better
probably there is an armada with enough
cages for all of our dragon vein
this is a new kind of element we need to
find the hidden world I won't destroy
everything you realize
you're nothing without your dragon
if criminal succeeds there won't be any
dragons left and it's up to us to put an
end to it so what are you gonna do about
it
suit up gang we have one shot a thing
you brought a baby to a battle it
couldn't find a sitter
the hidden tomorrow's have really
touched the key right but inside
well what Kunis not a word
[Music]
you